russia is not calling this a war but
this is the destruction that ukrainians
are waking up to
this damage in the city of buja
northwest of kiev in the basement of a
hospital in the capital these babies
came into this world to the sound of
bombs and gunfire i came here on the
first day
of the war
for
because i was pregnant and
28 february
i had my son
his name is mark and
we are in safe here
the best
the best personal the best staff in the
world work works here and we are very
proud of them
the war is putting a strain on ukrainian
health services
most of our team have not left the
building since february 24th about 70
percent of staff stay here permanently
we take turns at work
while the young come into this world
oblivious the elderly are getting ready
to defend their rights
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has called upon citizens to
take up arms
every person who comes to ukraine with
weapons will be killed by this gun
81 year old french teacher piotr virgo
has answered that call as he prepares to
defend his village and country
ukraine will fight until the end putin
united ukraine you can put it this way
with his actions actually we came
together political parties religiously
literally in every way we were never as
united as we are now
the russian military continued to make
gains
people like pyotr are still holding out
with no electricity or heating for three
days
he's still staying put
assad beg al jazeera